ok ok ok aujourd'hui on va se parler de
samsung on va pas se parler de matériel
on va se parer de logiciels ça change un
petit peu je vous parlais de leur
dernière interface qui s'appelle one day
3 points en est sorti fin d'année
dernière en one you lie 3.0 qui
succédait au niveau du haut quand j'ai
compris un peu l'histoire et il avait
juste moi je voulais vous donner mon
retour pour vous montrer déjà les
dernières nouveautés dewa dubai 3.1
faire un tout petit peu du côté de
manuel
parce que pour moi c'est une des
meilleures expériences aujourd'hui qu'on
peut trouver sur android j'aime beaucoup
ce que nous propose ça me saoule au
niveau de toute la partie logicielle sur
un nuage
ici aux nouvelles 3.1 basé sur android
11 se tiennent à face qui est cool qui
est intéressante qui a quelques petits
sauts création va donc venir les
débusquer voit ce qu'il en est et si
vous n'avez pas de smartphone sanction
des biens peut-être que ça pourra vous
donner envie d'aller voir ce qui se
passe du côté de la marque puisque
l'expérience est très cool et que
souvent on sous-estimé une expérience
logiciel on en parle beaucoup mais pas
assez pas de blabla on va venir se poser
on va venir filmer directement ce
smartphone regarder cette expérience
logiciel mais puisqu'on vous pour dire
ce que vous en pensez bien évidemment en
bas on commentaire
[Musique]
ça vous connaissez vous déjà montré
c'est l'interface ou à nigré ça c'est la
3.1 donc toute dernière version super
bien donc tu vois les des applications
tout ça c'est bien vous avez votre
tiroir d'applications vous avez vos
notifications et surtout un truc qui est
assez sympa ici mais ça ce dû au nuage
3.0 sera forcément une nouveauté de vos
nouvelles trois points en tout ce que
vous allez pouvoir utiliser sur votre
panneau de raccourcis mettre un peu plus
bas plus précis donc l'idée c'est
d'utiliser à une main rebond aussi je le
tiens que soient plus simples comme ça
mais vous pouvez l'utiliser à une main
briser son la partie du bac donc là
c'est plutôt sympa vous retrouvez tous
vos différents raccourcis ici plutôt
bien alors nouveau décompte retrouver
sur moi nous y 3.0 c'est le fait de
pouvoir l'allumer et l'éteindre en
double tap en double tap il c'est un jeu
double tap il salue bon il ya un petit
côté pratique je des verrous que pendant
ton digital ça vous connaissez
l'histoire il ya tout cas je trouve
vraiment bien mais vraiment super
intéressant en termes de respect de la
vie privée lorsque vous allez sur une
photo dans votre galerie là j'ai pris
cela ne pouvait prendre n'importe
laquelle
et vous voulez la partage à quelqu'un eh
bien vous savez que vous avez des
métadonnées à l'intérieur de vos photos
et notamment vos données de
géolocalisation vous avez pas en
forcément envie que tout le monde y ait
accès à vos données de géolocalisation
lorsque vous la partagez donc vous
cliquez ici et là pouvaient venir
supprimer un des ces crises une version
blanc supprimer les données de position
ça va donc pas partager votre position
gps à toutes les personnes qui vont
recevoir ces photos donc ça sur ça
vraiment bien et ça va dans le bon sens
ici vous n'avez qu'à balayer sur la
gauche pour avoir accès à toutes vos
informations signé samsung l'un est
jolie infos sur bayrou vous en avez
plein de tous les côtés et classé actu
culture économie tout ça c'est
pratiquement ça vous connaissez une
nouveauté qui a été mis en place et qui
est super sympa vous venez pas comme si
vous désignez ici et vous balayer sur la
gauche vous permet de venir choisir
entre effectivement les actus samsung
qui volent sur le bas et google discover
personnellement j'ai un compte google
j'utilise google ça ça peut être
extrêmement intéressant je coche dans
google discover
ensuite j'en viens là et voyez lorsque
je viens à gauche j'ai donc si tout les
enfants qui vont être en lien avec ma
navigation essayer ça autre nouveauté
qui est très sympa pour la maison
connectée vous allez dans votre panneau
de raccourcis et ici vous le voyez
devait la partie appareils la partie
média moi c'est la partie appareil qui
va m'intéresser ici lorsque ça me saoule
va vous mettre en avant c'est forcément
smart 6 que ça fait partie de son
écosystème mais vous pouvez venir
choisir si vous le souhaitez aum
google chrome pour ça il vous faut
l'application google il vous faut un
compte google ou bien évidemment mais ça
vous permet de venir paramétrer votre
maison donc ici vous avez les appareils
la maison de venir choisir d'allumer
désactiver coupé mais lui bien et
compagnie donc ça c'est très très
pratique
autre nouveauté lorsque vous recevez un
appel et bien vous allez ici dans votre
application d'appels up ici trois petits
points paramètres et vous allez ici dans
arrière-plan d'appel vous avez
différents arrière comme ça c'est rigolo
notamment en vidéo ici
voyez ce qui va venir s'afficher
lorsqu'on va bien vous passez un coutil
vous avez celui là aussi qui est très
sympa voyez ça change un petit peu à
côté qui est très dynamique vous avez le
choix suis là aussi qui marche bien
c'est penser un peu à google c'est un
acte où cette espèce de forme là qui
viennent tomber dessus
why not autre paramètre cas c'est
intéressant vous allez ici justement
dans vos paramètres vous allez dans les
fonctions avancées et vous allez dans
cette partie là qui s'appelle
basculement des applications sur les
autres appareils alors moi j'ai activé
en fait ce que ça lui à faire ici c'est
que ça doit continuer ce que vous avez
commencé sur ses appareils sur notre
appareil notamment si vous avez une
tablette de samsung pourquoi pas ou un
autre smartphone
à vous de voir vous allez commencer à
faire des choses dans votre smartphone
et ça leur prendra de l'autre côté alors
les applications prise en charge en a
pas énormément il ya cinq sur internet
samsung note mais voyez pour la partie
de notes et notamment sur un samsung
galaxy note ça peut aussi être très
intéressant pour ça que vous bien
évidemment un compte samsung mais dans
l'idée pourquoi pas c'est assez
intéressant
une nouveauté assez rigolote si par
exemple vous avez fait une photo qui est
un truc que vous voulez venir effacé un
truc où quelqu'un à vous de voir
et bien c'est très facile vous avez une
nouveauté qui vous permet de le faire
vous allez ici dans vos paramètres vous
venez juste en haut ici à droite et vous
avez le lab et dans le lab vous venez
activée
l'effaceur d'objets alors bon mois il
était désactivée par défaut je l'activer
et ensuite vous revenez sur votre photo
et là vous avez cette petite icône en
bas ici qui apparut vocaux chez dessus
et vous venez appuyé sur ce que vous
voulez supprimer par exemple ici d'un
bon pote derrière qui fait la photo je
veux qu'il parte
hop je sélectionne je fais effacer ça
calcule voilà bon ça me va supprimer
s'est pas complètement magique c'est un
peu bizarre qui va dépend bien
évidemment de la complexité de la scène
ici en tout cas je vois plus sa tête
c'est très bizarre je sais nager
l'objectif mais j'appuie sa tête donc
bon voyons pourquoi payet lille en
arrière c'est rigolo en tout cas si vous
voulez vous pouvez le faire
autre nouveauté je voulais montrer
lorsque je vous ai présenté ce nouveau
samsung galaxy s 21
et bien c'est dans votre mode photo vous
allez dans plus et vous avez ici la vue
du réalisateur vue du réalisateur qui
vous permettra de venir choisir entre
votre caméra de cellfish foyer taxe ac -
ici chantraine fils unique où vous allez
bien et vous switchez si entre vos trois
caméras grand temps du très grand temps
les téléobjectifs entre nouveautés qu'on
retrouve aussi sur mon niveau eal3
poison et bien ça va être le mode single
take 2.0 et sur le mode single take 2.0
ce que vous avez de bien si vous pouvez
venir ici choisir ce que vous allez voir
capture et vidéos filtrer photofiltre et
des clips avec des effets de vitesse les
portraits des photos large où régnait
une surveillance des vidéos ça vous
n'aviez pas avant c'est une nouveauté
justement de one way trois poisons
apparaît donc vraiment de venir créer
les single take que vous voulez alors
qu'avant c'était strictement impossible
de venir autant profondeur dans les
paramètres
toi qui as intéressant surtout cette
période accentué télétravail vous allez
dans vos paramètres vous êtes dans les
fonctions avancées et vous allez
retrouver ici tout en bas les effets
pour les appels visio vous pouvoir
retrouver en arrière-plan que ce soit
sur google duo ou sur zoom et bien soit
un flou d'arrière-plan vous verra vous
mais tout le reste au sahara flou pour
dire protéger l'intimité de votre maison
et notamment lorsque vous travaillez ou
alors une couleur vous et tous dressent
en couleur ou alors carrément une image
si vous le souhaitez vous venez trouver
une image dans votre galerie par exemple
je sais pas - une image avec un panorama
ici issu de la ville de clermont ferrand
c'est en tout cas ça c'est sympa et
c'est une nouveauté qui ont plusieurs
vraiment s'adapter à l'air du temps
entre nouveautés dans votre application
horloge claque ici eh bien vous avez une
toute nouvelle option qui apparaît
lorsque vous cliquez sur les trois
petits points c'est définir l'heure du
coucher vous ne l'aviez pas bon ça c'est
une nouveauté qui est intéressante
notamment pour le maintien de la
régularité de votre sommeil
vous avez vu c'est écrit noir sur blanc
vous allez sur suivant et vous
définissez l'heure à laquelle vous allez
vous coucher moins 22 heures c'est un
petit peu de tout on va dire allégeance
à -6 à 23 heures histoire d'être sûre et
moi j'aime me lever à 7h à 17h 20 le
matin je dors donc en tout 8h20 bravo je
suis fort ramassé cris chinois semblant
ensuite je fais suivant et ça me permet
d'avoir une notification de rappel avant
d'aller me coucher histoire de me
préparer d'aller brosser les dents et
des prêts au lit à 23 heures lorsque le
modifier cinq minutes avant à l'heure du
coucher aucune alerte procès pénaux m
une petite histoire de me préparer à
aller dormir donc ça je me sens vraiment
très très cool et ensuite je peux mettre
le mode heure du coucher
ça me permettra de basculer l'écran en
échelle de gris est désactivé leçon d
appel
en gros ça me permet d'accéder à mon
sommeil tout doucement tranquillement
mais ça je trouve ça vraiment
extrêmement mal hein je peux également
paramétrer du coup mon horloge
moi par exemple je me réveille que la
semaine n'est pas le week-end samedi et
dimanche je décroche mon horloge vibreur
le nombre de rappels et compagnie et
c'est terminé
autre petite nouveauté pour vos vidéos
qui est assez sympa vous venez si dans
votre mode photo vous venez d'en vidéo
et vous venez choisir ici directement et
très facilement la résolution ça vous
évite de passer dans un autre menu c'est
facile vous cliquez là et vous
choisissez pourrait monter jusqu'à 8 cas
à 24 images par seconde et ensuite vous
dites par exemple je filme et onu hd à
60 images par secondes je peux je m en
full hd en automatique je peux enfin
voyez c'est très facile pour venir soit
chez d'un mode à l'autre
une petite nouveauté qui assez rigolote
c'est au niveau de la paramétrage de
vaud vibrations pour vos notifications
vous avez une fois plus dans vos
paramètres vous allez ici dans son et
vibrations et vous voyez ici vous aviez
déjà le modèle de vibrations pour les
appels en hausse et comment est-ce que
ça allez vibrer en fonction de vos
appels up deux fois lassé façon continue
toc toc m'enfin bref je vous passe un
peu l'histoire et maintenant vous
retrouver la même chose exactement pour
avoir un modèle de vibrations pour vos
notifications ça vous permet de
différencier en fait le type de
vibrations vous allez avoir pour savoir
si c'est un appel pour savoir si c'est
une notification
donc pourquoi pas ce mot est assez
rigolo voilà pour ces quelques
nouveautés seront à nivelles trois
points en tout cas parce que jamais si
c'est l'expérience c'est simple c'est
pratique c'est rapide qui ont leurs
applications ou avoir une navigation par
gestes - il vous permet bien évidemment
en plus d'avoir votre mode sombre et
votre mode clair c'est pas une nouveauté
mais c'est très pratique pour ceux
qu'ils l'aiment moi j'aime beaucoup
c'est simple c'est intuitif c'est
lisible c'est bien classés bravo samsung
voilà donc pour toutes ces infos ses
astuces sur wall dubai trois points aux
dites moi comment vous le trouvez ça
vous intéresse vous pouvez vous laisser
tenter
et si vous avez déjà un smartphone de
samsung est ce que vous connaissiez ses
astuces mois il faut déjà avoir bonne
humeur trois ans déjà que vous soyez un
jour mais est-ce que vous connaissiez ce
que ça vous intéresse
mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire l on se retrouve très vite
pour continuer à parler tech et oui
parce que croyez moi oui croyez moi ils
appellent de raconter des bisous l'amour
des coeurs et la pâtisserie
à bientôt ciao